[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans auditions
publics une heure un invité sur Public
Sénat et la Chaîne Parlementaire tous
les lundis soir à 19h30 et nous recevons
ce soir marine Tondelier bonsoir à vous
marine tourdeliers vous êtes secrétaire
national d'Europe Écologie les vers
cette émission vous vous en doutez sera
largement consacrée aux violences la
sixième nuit redoutée qu'on a qu'on
vient de passer a été nettement plus
calme est-ce provisoire est-ce dur à
personne ne le sait mais au moins
peut-on tirer déjà des leçons quelles
sont vos propositions au-delà des
slogans on est heureux de vous entendre
tout à l'heure Isabelle borne reçoit
tous les présidents de groupe en ce
moment du groupe parlementaire à
Matignon Emmanuel Macron lui s'est
entretenu avec la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale et le président du
Sénat tout à l'heure et enfin le
président recevra demain à midi 220
maires qui ont été touchés par les
violences donc il y a à la fois un
dispositif un retour alors dans les rues
et une concertation politique est-ce la
bonne méthode vous avez été très
longtemps conseillère d'ailleurs
toujours conseillère d'opposition à la
mairie d'Hénin-Beaumont mais IRM depuis
2014 au passage mais ça vous donne une
bonne expérience aussi de la gestion
municipale comment expliquer que cette
colère
s'abattent aussi sur les élus de cette
façon là on vous entendra tout à l'heure
Brigitte boucher et tam-train nuit pour
vous poser toutes les questions
d'actualité ainsi que Vincent roux Yves
Thréard à bordera les questions
politiques vous avez accepté vous en
remercie de débattre avec François
Jolivet député horizon il abordera deux
thèmes à la fois l'état de la police et
le logement ce sera dans une bonne
quarantaine de minutes d'abord quelques
questions si vous voulez bien pour
introduire les missions je le disais la
nuit a été plus calme la nuit dernière
tout le monde s'en félicite 157
interpellations il y en avait eu
1311 dans la nuit de vendredi à samedi
donc le gap est considérable c'est une
amélioration pourquoi parce que le
dispositif policier a été dissuasif moi
je suis pas expert des questions de
sécurité je vais pas faire semblant que
je suis dans la salle de commandement et
que j'entends les analyses des uns et
les autres mais j'imagine que déjà il y
a beaucoup beaucoup d'arrestations et
des comparutions immédiates donc
forcément le vivier de gens qui
participent et violences s'épuisent et
puis je pense que tout le monde s'épuise
tout court d'ailleurs y compris les
forces de l'ordre pour qui ça doit être
extrêmement difficile et je pense aussi
aux pompiers aux élus locaux qui vous
l'avez dit sont en première ligne nous
on est on a fait hier une réunion de
tous nos mers écolos y compris les mers
d'arrondissement avec les parlementaires
et ce qui nous décrivait extrêmement
compliqué on a Christian métairie mer à
Arcueil qui nous raconte le saccage de
sa mairie et son lieu de travail donc
c'est ça le défaite et comment il fait
pour les enfants pour l'accueil des
centres cet été ils se retrouvent alors
que depuis des années il se battent
souvent dans le désert pour avoir des
aides et pouvoir faire vivre leur
commune c'est des années de travail qui
parlent littéralement en fumée et il
nous racontait avec Patrice
le maire aussi écologiste à Colombes que
certains de leurs collègues qui allaient
à la rencontre des jeunes dans la rue
pour essayer de pacifier les choses pour
la première fois ont dû battre en
retraite sous les jets de projectile et
donc c'est sûr qu'il y aura un avant et
un après en tout cas alors précisément
on va revenir dans le détail c'est très
intéressant parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
mairie évidemment dirigés par des vers
en effet qui ont subi ces attaques
Vincent Jean Brun
incarne aujourd'hui peut-être le
traumatisme le plus important de ce
point de vue là puisque des jeunes ont
tenté d'attaquer sa maison dans laquelle
était sa famille ses deux enfants sa
femme dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche
est-ce que Europe Écologie Les Verts a
été représentée au rassemblement des
mères solidaires avec Vincent Jean Brun
tout à l'heure on le rappelle il est
maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses premièrement
moi je lui ai fait un texto dès que j'ai
appris cette nouvelle un texto auquel il
a il a répondu on a fait des messages
sur les réseaux sociaux immédiats au nom
de tous les écologistes et puis oui moi
j'ai été moi-même devant ma mère devant
ma mairie à midi avec
beaucoup militants écologique mais le
rassemblement un petit peu plus tard là
il est rose vous y êtes allé ou pas
est-ce qu'il y avait des mères écolo 94
était présent mais il fallait en même
temps être dans sa mairie enfin vous
voyez il se passe beaucoup de corps en
même temps en tout cas nous sommes très
solidaire de semaine mais il est maire
et il est élu donc beaucoup de mères et
des lus se sont solidarisés faut pas
oublier quand même qu'il y a aussi
beaucoup de gens qui ont vécu des choses
traumatiques un des des logements privés
qui brûlaient avec des enfants à
l'intérieur il y en a eu d'autres pas
d'élus mais mais quand même il y a eu
des surveillants pénitentiaires qui
étaient repérés et poursuivi des
policiers aussi dans des adresses ont
fuitées je veux pas que le problème
d'alliance envers les élus qui est réel
et dont il faut s'occuper et qui ne date
pas d'aujourd'hui on a connu
Saint-Brevin et puis d'autres événements
mais occulte les violences contre des
personnes dont peu de gens parlent aussi
dans les médias et ça je pense que c'est
important de le pointer aussi je vous
dis si vous êtes surveillant
pénitentiaire c'est un métier qui est
pas simple et on parle des conditions de
détention dans les prisons il y a aussi
les conditions de l'exercice de ces
métiers là quand votre adresse fuite et
que vous êtes livré en pâture dans la
que vous habitez c'est des choses bien
sûr et on a extrêmement traumatique et
on a vu des policiers traquer de cette
façon là avec des enfants de policiers
qui n'osent pas dire que leurs parents
sont policiers juste la même manière on
parle des des biens des commerçants qui
ont brûlé il faut les aider vite pas
juste en accélérant les assurances mais
l'État doit les aider il y a aussi des
gens privés qui ont perdu par exemple
des voitures des logements
aux élus et s'inquiète pour les élus
c'est un risque aussi mais j'entends
votre empathie
il y a un trouble à gauche après le
refuge Jean-Luc Mélenchon d'appeler au
calme c'est simple d'appeler au calme
c'est une manifestation verbale un souci
d'apaisement est-ce que vous êtes sur la
ligne de Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a refusé
encore hier de le faire sur LCI si vous
me posez la question c'est que vous
n'avez pas entendu mes déclarations
précédentes moi j'ai toujours dit que
bien sûr il fallait calmer les choses
mais que le calme ne se décrétait pas
qu'il se construisait et donc je pense
avoir été pour le coup très pardon je
vous ai entendu mais je voudrais que je
n'ai pas moi je n'ai pas votre question
à passer mon temps à commenter les
tweets et les déclarations de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon je suis écologiste j'ai envie
de parler des propositions des
écologistes et alors si vous ne voulez
pas le faire je comprends mais si vous
voulez pas dire vous clarifier parce que
honnêtement c'est pas très clair le fait
de ce que je dis pas très non c'est pas
parce que par le simple fait de ce que
je dis je ne dis pas la même chose que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon d'ailleurs il vous
aura pas échappé que nous ne sommes pas
dans le même parti et que sur ce sujet
comme sur d'autres nous avons des
différences voir des désaccords que vous
ne dites pas pour autant est-ce que vous
dites que vous est-ce que vous appelez
au calme et toujours dit mais je veux
bien qu'on non c'est pas clair
que quand ça ne l'est pas la même chose
mais je veux bien qu'on appelle à ce que
ça veut dire calme calme ça veut dire ce
qui n'est pas troublé et agité et
j'aimerais bien savoir dans les six
derniers mois voir dans les dernières
années quand ça a été calme en fait
notre vie n'est pas calme et je suis
désolé on peut jouer à la relativisation
mais là il y a eu il y a eu des grande
violence c'est pas pareil toujours
condamné toute forme de violence je
viens d'un parti qui est non violent
depuis des décennies qui prônent la
non-violence qui prennent parfois la
désobéissance civile mais qui est par
principe non violente je n'ai pas de
problème de rapport avec la violence
mais moi de la violence j'en vois tout
le temps et tout et ça me fatigue je
vois de la violence dans les débats
parlementaires je vois de la violence
dans le débat public la violence
politique
et évidemment que les images qu'on voit
depuis quelques jours et ce que
subissent certains n'ont compatriotes en
priorité d'ailleurs dans les quartiers
populaires est extrêmement violent et
extrêmement inquiétant et je ne sais pas
comment comme ça en quelques jours on
reviendra au calme je vais pas à la
normale on va pas compliquer
je pense effectivement que vous appelez
tout le monde
à l'apaisement pour ensuite pouvoir
construire des solutions oui mais
j'appelle tout le monde à l'apaisement
et quand j'entends des mises dire il
faut appeler au calme et d'ailleurs
c'est un tel un tel Intel qui sont
correspondables des violences dans les
villes quand j'entends mieux qualifier
ses opposants de terroristes bah ça
m'inquiète aussi énormément parce que la
différence entre ces jeunes et lui c'est
lui les ministres de l'intérieur alors
et donc je pense que c'est le risque
qu'on est en train d'encourir c'est
qu'il y a une dérapage permanent de tout
le monde contre tout le monde et c'est
extrêmement difficile d'appeler au calme
en fait dans ces conditions
tout le monde a respecté des
responsabilités c'est ce que vous dites
Brigitte boucher les élus comme les
ministres Brigitte boucherie oui alors
bon vous n'avez pas clairement appelé au
calme si c'est très clair non pas
clairement en tout cas maintenant mais
est-ce que c'est pas un petit peu tout
de suite vous savez quand j'ai souhaité
par exemple quand on regarde
supplémentaires et que d'ailleurs j'ai
été très ciblé pour avoir dit ça et je
me rends compte que il y a quelques
jours dire j'espère qu'il y aura pas de
mort et je pense aux élus locaux qui
sont en première ligne c'était on se
faisait vilipender pour avoir dit ça
faut voir aussi que de jouer
et vous n'étiez pas ni d'un côté mais
vous avez compris qu'il y aurait de
calme sans justice par ailleurs et
d'ailleurs c'est logique quand on dit
pas de justice pas de vérité pas de paix
c'est pas une menace c'est l'effet donc
je peux appeler à la calme et à la
justice que vous vouliez et à la vérité
mais on voit bien que on est dans une
situation difficile et que demander la
justice
tous les cas précédents et
malheureusement dans les cas à venir
tant que la loi de change pas donc c'est
un peu plus compliqué que ça évidemment
sur les causes peut-être Tom oui ce
week-end vous avez situé la mort de Noël
dans un long continuum de violences
policières et de racisme est-ce que vous
estimez que cette mort doit jeter l'eau
propre sur l'ensemble de la police sur
un système de la police
je pense qu'il y a un problème
systémique dans la police je ne pense
pas que tous les policiers en soi
individuellement responsables je pense
que ce policier porte une responsabilité
individuelle mais quand j'entends
Emmanuel Macron dire voilà son geste est
inexcusable et inexpliquéable il est une
excusable mais il est pas inexplicable
vous voyez un système derrière des
années qu'on essaye donc évidemment et
juste dire rien donc c'est sûr de la
police alors oui mais ça veut dire que
l'institution est problématique et lisez
le communiqué qu'a fait le syndicat
Alliance il y a deux jours vous serez
fixé sur la question ça ne veut pas dire
que chaque policier individuellement est
problématique quand vous êtes dans une
institution problématique d'ailleurs
vous pouvez être vertueux ou pas le donc
l'institution de la police parlez-en
d'ailleurs à certains policiers racisés
qui il y a eu des fuites il y a quelques
temps de vous savez des messageries
instantanées ou en fait il y avait des
policiers qui échangés entre eux il y
avait des choses atroces qui étaient
dites sur leur sur leurs collègues
racisées qui
qui était victime au quotidien de choses
en moyenne alors c'est peut-être aussi
leur métier qui les fait voter ça enfin
tout est sûrement lié mais oui il y a un
problème et je trouve extrêmement
délétère que quand on essaye de
l'adresser dans le débat public on
aurait répondu c'est antique bah non en
fait c'est un petit flic il y a un
problème de racisme dans la police c'est
comme ça quand vous voyez que la famille
de Noël dit nous on n'en veut pas à
l'ensemble de la police on en veut à un
policier est-ce que votre prise de
parole allait responsable mais c'est
normal que la famille Naël en veille à
ce policier en particulier ils ont tué
pas la police qualifie pas la police
je veux que les relations de confiance
entre notre population et sa police
s'améliore et je pense que ça nécessite
quelques évolutions législatives et pas
mais
là c'est un problème de raciste quand
vous êtes un jeune garçon et si vous ne
croyez pas les jeunes parlez-en avec
leur maman le front de mer par exemple
c'est des associations dans plusieurs
quartiers populaires de la ville en
France comme 7% de la population
française un quartier populaire de la
ville c'est maman elle vous explique que
leur fils du simple fait qu'il soit
racisé à 10 à 20 fois plus de chances
d'être chaque jour oui mais moi ce que
je pense
humilié et donc oui il y a des règles et
aussi la politique du chiffre et aussi
la politique du chiffre qui fait que oui
mais là dans le cas
oui je pense que ça adresse un continuum
de violence policière un continuum de
racisme va continuerum de de d'après
colonisation qui n'a jamais été vraiment
adressée géré et un continuum de
ségrégation dans ce pays où on parc dans
des quartiers ce qu'on ne sait pas gérer
autrement et et ce qui vous êtes pour
supprimer énormément de violence dans la
société mais aussi pour la personne qui
habite dans ce que vous voulez supprimer
tous les contrôles d'identité c'est le
cas de l'intellectuel Patrick weyke qui
dit ça sert à rien à part astigmatiser
je pense qu'on pourrait commencer par se
dire qu'on donne un récipissé aux gens
qui sont contrôlés pour que ça leur
arrive pas 15 fois par jour c'est la
base ça fait des années que toutes les
assauts qui adressent un peu
sérieusement sujet le disent si on n'est
pas capable suite à ce qui s'est passé
de prendre ce genre de mesure pas là
aujourd'hui ce serait complètement
inaudible on doit être dans le dans le
retour au calme pour dire ces mots qui
vous font plaisir mais mais vous avez
naturellement
de l'entendre et donc le disons-le mais
si on ne prend pas ses mesures là alors
on est condamné à revu ce genre de
situation et d'ailleurs je je regrette
que dans ce pays on ne parle des
banlieues que quand s'afflambe et donc
là en fait quand on dit calme beaucoup
de gens dans les quartiers entendent bah
on va ok il y aura du calme tant mieux
et après
on essaie de poser des questions les
unes après les autres et d'avoir vos
réponses elles sont donc je suis pas de
suppression du contrôle
ça peut vous intéresser vous réclamez on
l'a entendu un depuis le début de cette
émission l'abrogation de la loi de 2017
la loi de 2017 qui a aligné le régime
des policiers sur celui des gendarmes en
matière de refus d'obtente péril et de
régime de légitime défense vous proposez
quoi à la place bah il y avait une
situation avant cette mesure en 2017 le
gouvernement Cazeneuve fait cet article
l434-1 qui c'est quoi qui vous pose
problème qui est très flou parce qu'à
l'époque il y avait des députés
écologistes dont Serge de Coronado Noël
ma mère il y avait des députés
communistes aussi de André sa chaîne qui
avait dit la disposition est floue et
donc elle si nous déjà dans l'hémicycle
on l'interprète pas pareil elle sera
interprété diversesment sur le terrain
de permis de tuer c'est ce que dit Henry
Leclerc par exemple c'est pas mes mots
mais ce qui s'est passé c'est que dans
la gendarmerie ils ont fait une
circulaire qui était plutôt assez
restrictive de cette mesure et
d'ailleurs il y a eu très peu de sujets
dans le jardinerie parce que la
gendarmerie
c'est aussi des gens qui sont ancrés sur
des territoires et qu'on en voit pas non
formés dans les territoires les plus
difficiles en termes de maintien de
l'ordre de l'autre côté dans la police
la circulaire a été interprétée de
manière pour le coup très extensive et
il y a eu plus 39% de tirs et 5 fois
plus de morts 5 fois plus là c'est 18
années
non mais c'est vrai là vous ne venez de
me citer l'IGPN qui en plus pose
problème donc ça me confirme dans ce que
je dis mais vous voyez bien qu'il y a
c'est des chercheurs indépendants qui
fournissent ces données donc j'ai
tendance à avoir des croire et ou alors
on me donne d'autres chiffres mais voyez
c'est 18 derniers mois il y a eu 16
morts par refus d'obtempérer et pour
répondre à votre question
se trouve avec beaucoup beaucoup plus de
refus de tempéré aussi ils font oui
parce que c'est qualifié différemment et
donc la quasi intégralité de ces
personnes étaient des personnes racisées
donc 16 morts suite à des refusants
intempéries en 18 mois en Allemagne il y
en a eu un en 10 ans alors peut-être que
c'est dû aussi à notre moment légiférer
là sous le coup de l'émotion c'était un
peu ce qui avait déjà été fait
les écolog ont déposé une proposition de
loi sur le sujet pour abroger cette loi
en décembre il se trouve qu'on avait
plus de groupes avant ça vous a pas
échappé mais ça fait des années qu'on
demande ça et en 2017 déjà cette
question là avait été posée par nos
députés dans l'hémicycle donc ça paraît
évident que la loi va devoir chanter et
je vais vous dire quand j'ai lu le
communiqué de presse d'alliance que tout
le monde a en tête ou un coup c'est
extrême qui n'ont pas donc il y a trois
jours alliance et l'une sa police qui a
eux deux représentent je crois que c'est
47,5% de votes aux élections
professionnelles donc ils sont très
majoritaires et en 5 il a signé et une
sa police les deux il était cologoté une
ça a même dû se désolidariser de une
salade
de ordre sauvage de nuisibles moi en
plus en tant qu'echologiste ça fait des
années qu'on se bat pour que certaines
espèces animales ne soient plus
qualifiées de nuisibles ces stigmatisant
pour les renards etc alors pour des gens
je vous dis pas quand on voit ce genre
de vocabulaire on voit bien qu'il y a un
problème dans la police et dans dans la
manière d'utiliser en fait et donc quand
on voit se communiquer moi je
prête comme ils ont bien compris que la
loi elle est devoir changer et donc ils
interviennent très lourdement pour
rappeler au gouvernement leur pouvoir de
nuisances finalement c'est une forme
d'intimidation
la police est en train de d'essayer
d'intimider en fait le gouvernement
disant vous prévient si vous bougez une
oreille si vous changez cette loi parce
que évidemment il y a une majorité
culturelle en France pour vous changer
cette loi tout le monde voit bien qu'il
y a un problème bah nous on rendra les
armes nous on fera de la iron d'entrera
en résistance alors on va passer limite
ça fait deux fois déjà qu'on l'évoque
vous avez et vous êtes non mais vous
avez raison c'est normal non non mais
vous l'avez bien on a bien compris et on
comprend pourquoi vous êtes tout à fait
hostile et par rapport à ça non mais
c'est vrai
la suite et mettre ou pas en fait quand
on a des sous ce type de est-ce que vous
iriez jusqu'à proposer de dissoudre un
syndicat qui a des termes aussi violents
à l'égard de jeunes ah moi je pense
qu'il faut arrêter de vouloir dissoudre
tous les gens qui sont pas d'accord avec
le corps
non mais je trouve que politiquement les
sujets
les opposants politiques donc ce serait
pas ma méthode si on était au pouvoir
Emmanuel Macron a parlé de
responsabilité des parents de garder
leurs enfants à domicile est-ce que vous
trouvez qu'il a eu raison de faire ça et
finalement est-ce que ça a pas été
efficace alors il se trouve que j'ai
discuté hier avec la première ministre
on a eu un échange pas sur toute
l'actualité mais ce sujet est venu sur
la table moi ça m'inquiète énormément
parce que je vais vous dire je l'ai déjà
j'ai passé plusieurs fois sur des
plateaux télé quelques temps à expliquer
quand on parlait du fils de Valérie
Pécresse du fils de de Morano du fils de
Zemmour qu'il fallait arrêter de définir
les parents par leurs enfants et les
erreurs des enfants par leurs parents je
trouve que c'est une très mauvaise
manière d'apporter de d'amener le débat
et si je j'ai été amené à défendre ces
personnes quand il s'est attaqué sur
leurs enfants alors que c'est pas du
tout mes amis politiques je suis
d'autant plus inquiète quand on parle de
gens qui habitent dans les quartiers
délaissés de la République qui sont 7%
de la population française qui sont deux
fois moins avoir du travail qui sont
trois femmes même temps qui ont 13 ans
et donc
voyez ce que je veux dire évidemment
l'autopartité parentale ça existe c'est
légal mais ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
c'est que on n'est pas égal quand on est
enfant dans ce pays mais on n'est pas
égal quand on est parents je mets au
défi beaucoup de gens qui nous donnent
des leçons de morale sur les plateaux
télés d'aller élever des enfants dans
ses quartiers dans ses écoles d'ailleurs
donc il fuit et il contourne la carte
scolaire pour pas que leurs enfants et
dans ses écoles
quand vous avez aucune perspective à
donner à vos gamins qui voit bien que ça
fait trois générations qui sont dans le
même quartier avec des qui font des
demandes pour changer de quartier on dit
ah bah déjà soit il y a pas de nouveau
appartement soit il y en a un autre bah
aussi
la première des ministres
de notre échange il faut pas
culpabiliser des parents qui sont en
application je trouve que c'est la
double peine parce qu'en fait être
parent dans ces quartiers c'est
quasiment mission impossible alors ça
doit pas l'être puisque il y en a plein
qui c'est pas les enfants de tout le
monde qui sont dans les émeutes mais je
pense que juger de loin en disant moi
mes enfants si j'habitais là jamais il
ferait ça c'est aller un peu vite en
besogne donc ça veut dire qu'avec
Dupond-Moretti à tort de de vouloir
durcir l'application de cet article à
227 17 du code pénal qui dit qu'il faut
éventuellement condamner les parents
qu'il faut qu'ils sont responsables qui
doivent payer pour les dégâts toute
façon on va arriver dans un moment de
durcissement puisque la seule réponse de
ce gouvernement pour l'instant alors
peut-être que c'est dans l'immédiat
qu'il y aura d'autres choses après mais
c'est la force et moi je voulais qu'on
revienne au fondamentaux à Blaise Pascal
qui disait la justice sans la force et
impuissant parce que toujours des gens
qui auront pas envie de respecter mais
la force sans la justice et tyrannique
vous voyez c'est pas une écolo je sais
pas quoi qui dit ça c'est Blaise Pascal
et donc lui il a toujours dit qu'il
fallait mettre ensemble la justice et la
force ensemble et donc que il faut faire
ensemble ce qui est juste que ce qui est
juste soit fort et ce qui est fort soit
juste et aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression
dans ce pays que la justice c'est pas
une valeur forte pas la justice tribunal
mais la justice sociale la justice
environnementale ça c'est pas en train
de se renforcer c'est plutôt en train de
se dégrader et que dans le même temps ce
qui est fort n'est pas juste et
aujourd'hui je suis désolé de vous dire
que outre les violences là immédiate
qu'on vit mais la manière dont Monsieur
Darmanin dissout ses O hommes politiques
quand vous avez en trois mois un
problème avec la LDH avec anticorps avec
des partis politiques que vous qualifiez
de terroristes ça fait beaucoup en fait
il y a un continuum de baisse des
libertés publiques de baisse du de la
possibilité de la violence aussi de
l'autre côté de la désobéissance civile
c'est pas la même chose
quand vous venez avec des boules de
pétanque et avec des haches justement
si vous avez par exemple
peut-être que je suis somnambule mais je
pense pas non mais je parle pas de vous
mais justement
civiles
pour vous la violence peut être une
solution dans certains cas jamais
d'accord jamais très mal comprise je
vous le demande
bientôt voir 50 ans la violence vont
bientôt avoir 50 ans d'histoire de non
violence c'est notre action violente que
nous vous ne qualifiez pas de violente
nous on prône dans des actions violentes
que vous ne qualifiez pas violente non
prendre dans certains cas la
désobéissance civile
absolument pas dans certains cas une
femme
allait avorter alors c'était interdit
c'était illégal c'était pas illégitime
mais c'était pas violent non plus la
désobéissance civile par principe elle
n'est pas violente mais elle vous dit
juste c'est que parfois ne pas respecter
la loi sur une action symbolique pour
attirer l'action sur quelque chose genre
quand vous jetez de la soupe sur un
tableau moi en plus je vous dis ça je le
fais pas mais quand on dit jeune ils ont
jeté de la soupe sur de l'art et alors
ça dérange enfin alors
un jeune qui incendie une voiture pour
passer un message
des jeunes qui faisaient ça je
revendiquais tout ce qu'on discute
depuis tout à l'heure par ailleurs voilà
c'est que on est dans un moment
d'émotion ou moi j'ai envie qu'on
invoque aussi les sciences sociales
qu'on nous explique enfin il y aura
beaucoup d'analyses fêtes en fait mais
là je pense que c'est pas le bon moment
on va continuer à parler notamment des
violences faites aux élus et notamment
au maire comment comprendre aujourd'hui
que les mères soient pris pour si mon on
a parlé tout à l'heure de Vincent Jean
Brun le maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses mais il
y a aussi mon Luçon il y a aussi
Pontoise qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui
peut expliquer qu'aujourd'hui ces élus
de la République soit la cible des et de
ses émeutes ben je pense qu'il y a une
perte de repères et de confiance dans la
chose publique il y a quelques temps
Emmanuel Macron a parlé de Norbert Elias
enfin de la décibilisation je pense vous
rappelez donc les gens qui ont dit ah
mais c'est Albert Camus c'est l'extrême
droite non non c'est Norbert Elias bon
manifestement lui et ses conseillers
avait pas lu le livre jusqu'au bout
parce que c'est ce qui explique Norbert
Yas quand il parle de décibilisation
c'est que dans une société il y a les
classes sociales supérieures qui
normalement c'est eux qui transmettent
le contenu des règles et la manière de
s'y rapporter aux classes populaires
pour faire simple et donc il dit à
partir du moment où c'est même classe
supérieurs sont dans l'avidité dans la
tromperie dans le cynisme dans le mépris
dans la corruption alors il y a plus de
repères et ça crée chez une forme de ça
se traduit par des formes imprévisibles
de réaction et il parle notamment de
tension d'incivilité d'agression et de
féroc
vous les mettez toutes dans le même sac
non je dis que les élites anciens quand
même majoritairement issus
je vais vous dire moi dans ma ville le
temps dans ma ville c'était les mineurs
alors c'était l'exploitation de l'homme
par l'homme mais il y avait des
avantages sociaux et puis les mines ont
fermé on a dit non non elles vont pas
fermer moi ils ont fermé quand même on
le savait et puis à la place il y a eu
du clientélisme politique il se trouve
que moi mon maire en 2008 il a été
révoqué de ses fonctions de mer par le
Conseil des ministres pour 18 chefs
d'incubation comment vous voulez après
ça que les gens aient confiance dans le
politique
quel est le principe quel est le rapport
avec les journalistes d'ailleurs les
politiques et les journalistes sont de
moins en moins aimés compris
vécu comme des des gens qu'on écoute
avec attention en disant ça m'intéresse
qui va dire par la population ce ne sont
plus des institutions des institutions
sanctuarisées et donc d'ailleurs il y en
a plus beaucoup
comment on fait est-ce qu'il faut par
exemple aggraver les peines en cas
d'agression d'élus c'est une proposition
qui avait été faite sur la locmi et
maintenant qui pourrait revenir avec la
loi sur la justice passer par exemple à
7 ans de prison et 100000 € d'amende
mais je peux vous refaire les citations
de Blaise Pascal d'avant c'est bien sûr
on peut renforcer l'arsenal judiciaire
c'est pas un début mais juste ça ça
suffira pas bien sûr c'est par ailleurs
sur le maire de Saint-Brévin je rappelle
quand même que l'État est en carence
fautive manifeste puisque pour mettre
entretenu avec ma collègue l'Europe
Écologie Les Verts qui est dans son
conseil municipal il a demandé interdire
cette manif il a demandé à être mis sous
protection policière on lui a jamais
répondu jamais et donc il y a un
problème en fait dans ce pays de
maintien de l'ordre qui maintient pas
grand chose mais sur la question des
agressions est-ce qu'il faut quand même
aller plus loin dans la réponse la
réponse pénale dans dans le montant des
amendes on peut considérer que comme
c'est un élu c'est une circonstance
aggravante mais la réalité c'est qu'il y
a différentes stations de violente
contre les pompiers contre les policiers
contre les instituteurs à l'hôpital
public et que d'accord ou pas mais ce
que je vais vous dire c'est que
tout simplement est-ce que vous
demanderez à mes collègues mais
peut-être qu'il y a besoin d'une mesure
symbolique et que ça ça même ça
rassurera les élus et si c'est ça
peut-être que c'est déjà ça mais très
sincèrement regardez la violence qui
monte contre contre tous les
représentants d'une forme de de de
hiérarchie de pouvoir de savoir passer
et alors
les solutions c'est aussi quand on a
quand les élus n'ont pas les moyens
d'agir ce qu'on décentralise des
compétences sans leur donner les moyens
bah la violence se tourne vers des élus
qui ont pas les moyens de faire on dit
aux gens d'aller voir votre corps donc
je vous interrompre une seconde alors
une solution il y a eu un plan banlieue
en 2011 est-ce que vous voyez une
solution je vais aller dire miracle mais
il y en a plusieurs mais c'était nous
une solution pour sortir de cette crise
et durablement
c'est à chaque fois la même histoire
c'est qu'en fait le cadre de vie est en
train d'être pris par les habitants moi
quand je veux voir des jardins partagés
des trucs c'est vraiment c'est des
habitants qui disent bah comme tout le
monde s'en fout nous on va prendre et
oui il y a eu en ruse on refait les
façades tout ça mais sans tout le reste
ou d'ailleurs il y a à la rue c'est quoi
le reste dans le petit bar à Montpellier
la rue ils ont dit bah les habitants
trouvés
un gymnase pour reconstruire une tour en
plus et donc c'est ça c'est encore plus
et ils leur ont mis un terrain de boule
de pétanque donc moi je leur dis bah
alors enfin ils me disait voyez c'était
rien de pétanque qu'ils avaient l'air
hyper fâché décalé le problème et ils me
disent bah on est à Montpellier en fait
on n'est pas Marseille nous personne ne
joue la pétanque donc là c'était nos
jardins partagés à la place il y a un
terrain de péton quand elle personne ne
joue ça sert de trucs pour les chiens et
donc vous voyez il y a un truc de on
peut pas faire ces quartiers penser ces
quartiers de sans les habits de
connexion les habitants repenser la
rénovation européenne en concert vous
allez trouver je suis une écolo naïve
merci
primordial pour la santé mentale c'était
un truc d'enfermement qui a un moment
fait que ça ne peut merci beaucoup à
vous et on accueille cent roux merci
beaucoup mesdames et on accueille
Vincent roux du Figaro life pour une
question à Marine tandelier Vincent
bonjour
bonjour Elisabeth bonjour marine
Tondelier question simple qu'est-ce que
vous inspire le déclenchement par la
Chine de la protection consulaire pour
se ressortissants qui se trouve
actuellement en France ou bien cette
déclaration de l'Algérie qui je cite
rappelle à la France sont devoir de
protection envers ses ressortissants
est-ce que vous trouvez ça fondée ou
est-ce que ça vous paraît pas un peu
exagéré
je suis pas naïve sur les ressorts aussi
diplomatiques et géopolitiques de ce
genre de mesure il y a toujours une
espèce de règlement de compte qui vise
aussi à salir l'image de la France
Internationale non mais peut-on en
vouloir vu les images qui circulent à la
télé de à des gens d'avoir peur de venir
en France la question c'est est-ce que
un français est plus
et plus en sécurité aujourd'hui en
France qu'en Algérie voilà je vous
laisse la question ouverte mais voilà on
voit bien que c'est toujours des débats
avec beaucoup de barrières pensées
géopolitiques
allez-y vite
vous pensez que les Français sont plus
en sécurité en Algérie que les Algériens
ne le sont en France c'est encore un
autre problème
c'est je vous laisse à vos à vos
suppositions on ira voir les
statistiques bon bah écoutez à Vincent à
tout à l'heure en tout cas
je vous ai répondu
la réponse c'est une non-réponge dans un
question je suis pas question je suis
pas Jean-Michel statistique qui invente
des chiffres quand je ne les ai pas donc
je vous laisse à vos suppositions merci
beaucoup Vincent à tout à l'heure désolé
mais c'est vrai que la liaison est un
peu compliquée et en face de vous vient
de s'installer Yves très a le directeur
adjoint de la rédaction du client
avant de d'entrer avec des questions sur
l'avenir électoral de votre formation
que vous dirigez maintenant
quelques questions encore quand même sur
ce qui vient de se produire en France
qui vient de se passer la première des
questions est-ce que parce qu'on sait
pas tellement penché sur les causes de
cette
de ce qui vient de se passer de ces
violences
est-ce que d'après vous il y a pas
d'avantage aujourd'hui de cause
finalement
identitaire que de cause économiques
sachant que
la Cour des comptes par exemple et bien
dit que 10 à 15 milliards d'euros tous
les ans mes pensées pour justement ces
quartiers difficiles et sensibles et que
leur rue également fait énormément de
rénovations urbaines et quand on voit la
ce qui s'est passé aux obsèques à la
marche blanche pour ce jeune homme la
semaine dernière si vous avez bien
regardé ça plaît davantage à une
manifestation de revendications car un
recueillement
en 2018
il y a beaucoup de choses dans votre
question y compris dans la formulation
de la question qui me pose problème
parce que vous dites
identitaire versus économique vous
oubliez une grosse cause qui est la
cause sociale
n'explique pas tout et n'excuse pas tout
mais c'est quand même un énorme sujet
qu'il faut prendre en compte quand on a
les chiffres de de ce qui se passe dans
ces quartiers des taux de pauvreté qui
sont trois fois plus importants que la
moyenne en France etc ça c'est la
première chose après cette manifestation
il se trouve que j'y étais et donc je
trouve que c'est assez fatigant ces
injonctions à comment il faut se
recueillir tout le monde ne se recueille
pas pareil et donc il se trouve que il y
a des cultures différentes même dans un
pays la France qui est plein et entier
égalité fraternité tout ce que vous
voulez on se recueille pas tous pareils
les enterrements ou quel mois je peux
assister selon les milieux sociaux selon
les régions c'est selon les religion il
faut le dire c'est pas la même chose et
donc je moi j'ai vu beaucoup de violence
notamment autour de la maman de Noël et
de regarder elle sourit c'est pourquoi
il sourit c'est vrai que ça frappait
beaucoup ceux qui ont vu et moi j'en ai
des avec des gens qui l'avaient
rencontré avant et après
cette ampleur généralement qu'on enterre
les morts mais il y a pas de règles en
fait et pour le coup j'ai trouvé
extrêmement violent que cette maman qui
venait de perdre son enfant ce qui est
le truc qu'on devrait jamais avoir à
vivre et en plus dans un truc
d'injustice notoire peut-être juste
qu'en fait quand elle a vu tous ces gens
arriver pour célébrer son fils elle a
été sincèrement émue et que l'émotion ne
se montre pas pareil chez tout le monde
et j'ai trouvé extrêmement violent ces
gens qui se permettaient du haut de leur
fil Twitter d'aller juger comment elle
aurait dû ou pas réagir et donc moi
j'étais dans cette marche j'ai pas pu
rester triste
c'est pas mes gestes c'est pas mes
gestes mais
alors quel est le problème deuxième
question sur toujours sur il y a une
cagnotte qui a été ouverte pour venir en
aide à la famille du policier une
cagnotte qui a un succès phénoménal plus
d'un million je crois d'euros ont été
mobilisés sur cette cagnotte
sur ce plateau
est-ce que ça vous choque
alors que une cagnotte justement a été
ouverte aussi pour venir en aide à cette
jeune à cette mère en deuillée et que
elle elle a beaucoup moins de succès bah
on s'est qui est l'auteur de cette
cagnotte ces gens Messia qui ne figure
notoire d'extrême droite et donc on sait
que cette cagnotte c'est pas juste de la
solidarité c'est un message politique il
y a peut-être des gens qui donnent juste
par solidarité je pense qu'il y a aussi
beaucoup de gens qui donnent pour
envoyer un message politique donc
je constate qu'il y a d'autres cagnottes
qui ont été fermées beaucoup plus
rapidement et donc là on voyait en
parler tout à l'heure de justice de ce
qui est légal ou pas bah là on a
quelqu'un qui tue quand même un jeune il
y aura une enquête qui dira pourquoi
comment etc mais on a quand même tous eu
cette vidéo et et une cagnotte de
solidarité se monte et atteint plus d'un
million d'euros c'est un sujet qu'est-ce
que ça raconte pardon qu'est-ce que
c'est traduit quand même on peut
s'interroger c'est vrai que c'est ça
peut paraître choquant la première
ministre vient de dire parce que
le fait qu'elle soit créée par quelqu'un
d'extrême droite ne contribue pas à
apporter l'apaisement même s'il n'est
pas du ressort du gouvernement de
décider ou non de son existence mais
quand même qu'est-ce que ça raconte ben
je pense que ça raconte ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure sur le racisme
systémique c'est à dire qu'en fait le
message que ça donne c'est quelqu'un aux
gens de ces quartiers c'est maman dont
je parlais tout à l'heure c'est
quelqu'un qui tue votre gamin
si une cagnotte de solidarité est
ouverte à la famille pour sa famille ils
peuvent avoir un million d'euros
de racisme systémique la France est-elle
un pays raciste
il y a du racisme en France comme dans
plein de sociétés je connais pas un seul
pays où il y a zéro racisme la
difficulté c'est qu'en France c'est
tabou d'en parler parce qu'on est dans
on en parle excusez-moi dans un contexte
extrêmement particulier
identitaire on en parle dans un contexte
extrêmement particulier pour avoir
essayé d'en parler plusieurs fois dans
d'autres contextes c'était tabou et dire
qu'il y avait du racisme dans la police
ce que nous nous remonte tout le temps
c'était être anti-flic et donc hop le
débat était terminé et on était
marginalisé et même stigmatisée pour
avoir même essayé d'en parler ce que je
constate c'est que dans le cas de Noël
s'il n'y avait pas eu cette vidéo
il y aurait eu la parole de ces deux
policiers lui la sienne n'existait plus
les deux autres passagers de la voiture
n'en parlons pas et puis voilà c'était
réglé à faire classer et que du coup on
se dit toutes ces histoires où il y
avait pas de vidéo ça donne quoi et donc
oui évidemment qui est un problème
c'est pas qu'un message de solidarité
stable et sage politique et qui en tout
cas est forcément reçu de manière
extrêmement violente par les gens qui
habitent ces quartiers qui disent si on
tue l'un de nos enfants c'est pas des
excuses comment les ratés une récompense
d'un million d'euros
au fait que la personne qui a ouvert
cette cagnotte est une personne qui est
politiquement très marquée c'est ça j'en
sais rien j'ai pas faire ça qui vous
autorise à dire que c'est raciste c'est
un truc aggravant dans le message mais
ça peut-être que lui il a utilisé aussi
sa force médiatique et ses réseaux pour
faire connaître cette cagnotte et que si
c'était un inconnu qui pense la même
chose que lui mais qui est inconnue ça
n'aurait pas eu la même portée il a mis
sa notoriété au service de cette
cagnotte il a mis tout son poids dans la
balance pour que le message qui soit
envoyé soit celui-là voilà ça veut dire
que l'extrême droite est plus simple
aussi en France ça ne fait nul doute
alors on va parler un peu des élections
quand même européennes qui ont lieu
l'année prochaine parce que c'est aussi
votre actualité vous vous êtes réunis le
week-end dernier et vous avez décidé
de organiser un vote qui va avoir lieu
je crois entre le 7 et le 11 juillet
vous me corrigez ou le 18 ouais prochain
par internet et il y a deux candidats
quelqu'un qu'on connaît assez bien parce
qu'il a il a exercé des fonctions de
direction dans votre mouvement David
Corman contre madame Marie Toussaint qui
est
une euro député
qui vient du nord je crois de la France
dans le bassin minier on a vécu
parisienne et à Bordeaux si vous voulez
tout savoir
est-ce que ce sont deux sensibilités
différentes ce sont deux excédents
candidats et moi je vais vous dire on
dit toujours mais toi tu soutiens qui
etc Il a tradition c'est que la
secrétaire nationale ou le secrétaire
national ne prennent pas position du
tout et reste en réserve et moi je
souvent je dis bah là je vais
contrecarrer un peu cette tradition et
je vais soutenir
les deux parce qu'en fait
et que l'un ou l'autre gagne j'en serai
ravi on va faire une très belle campagne
européenne en restant concentré sur les
sujets qui nous occupent l'écologie et
l'Europe de faire mieux de que Monsieur
Jadot il y a en 2019 on a toujours envie
de faire mieux mais je vais vous dire on
n'est pas nous on n'est pas dans des
objectifs chiffrés de il faut faire tel
score en fait on est concentré sur nos
objectifs des suffrages la dernière fois
on est concentré sur nos objectifs on
veut qu'il y ait un maximum de députés
écologistes dans ce Parlement européen
parce qu'on voit bien que chaque
bulletin vert qui est mis dans l'urne
aux européennes en France et dans les
autres pays d'Europe sert de curseur aux
dirigeants des pays européens et aux
différentes institutions de l'Europe
pour dire plus ou moins d'écologie et
donc ceux qui veulent plus d'écologies
qui sont inquiets de tout ce qui se
passe qui pensent qu'il faut plus
protéger notre environnement et donc
l'avenir de nos enfants mais aussi plus
de solidarité alors le bulletin vert
permet de faire les deux à la fois
ceux qui ont le droit de vote vous êtes
combien dans le groupe écologie
[Musique]
européen il y a de plus en plus de chefs
d'État qui souhaitent une pause
réglementaire
sur ce texte qui porte sur deux volets
restauration de la nature et pesticides
en raison alors il y a beaucoup de
raisons il y a d'abord eu les pays de
l'Est puis un certain nombre de pays
comme Chypre comme Irlande comme la
Grèce qui se sont ralliés au pays qui
veulent une pause pour des raisons qui
sont liées à l'inflation sont liées à la
guerre en Ukraine est-ce que ça vous
inquiète d'ailleurs Emmanuel Macron lui
aussi et l'Allemagne donc il y a quand
même beaucoup de force hostiles à ce que
ça soit mythe mise en oeuvre pardon
rapidement les choses sont claires les
enfants qui naissent en 2023 on ne sait
pas leur garantir que la planète sera
encore habitable pour l'année de leurs
30 ans et donc on peut demander toutes
les pauses qu'on veut la réalité est
celle-ci et il y a un moment où les
postes sont climaticides donc je veux
bien entendre plein de raisons et
notamment le fait de vouloir faire de la
justice environnementale tout en faisant
de la justice sociale qui ce qui est là
le seul manière acceptable de faire mais
la pose en matière de changement
climatique ne peut pas être une solution
il y aura jamais de pause au changement
climatique ni à l'effondrement de la
biodiversité ni à l'épuisement notre
source en eau et donc faire pause
peut-être que les politiques qui
arrivent la nature elle n'y arrive pas
mais bon ça m'inquiète pas ça vous
inquiète énormément vous voyez venir que
nous députés nous aurez députés
écologistes se battront à Strasbourg sur
le sujet la semaine prochaine à suivre
enfin du coup qu'on connaîtra d'ici là
oui le week-end prochain dimanche ou
samedi
l'écologie gagnera la fin que vous
verrez je vous présente mais vous le
connaissez François Jolivet merci avec
vous et encore une fois merci à tous les
deux d'avoir accepté le principe du
débat vous êtes député horizon monsieur
Jolivet et la première question que vous
voulez aborder vous êtes élu de l'Indre
c'est la question du logement question
très importante surtout en ce moment
on entend parler beaucoup aujourd'hui de
crise du logement et moi je fais partie
de celles et ceux qui pensent qu'on n'a
pas de crise du logement dans notre pays
qu'on a que des crises de parcours
résidentiel dans les territoires non non
ça ne fait pas un problème en moi en
moins parce qu'en fait si vous êtes à
chaîne sur ce il y a pas de crise du
logement au sens où on l'entend à Paris
ou dans l'Indre ou à Royan pour d'autres
raisons et en fait derrière ce mot crise
du logement ou bombe social c'est sur
les propos du ministre
on semble dire qu'il faut que de la
production que de la production qu'il
faut répondre à la demande vous incarnez
europécologie les Verts l'objectif c'est
sans doute de lutter d'abord contre la
production de gaz à effet de serre et et
j'entends pas trop parler de la
réhabilitation en masse parce qu'on peut
pas tenir de discours réhabiliter et
construire
et je voudrais vous entendre
j'aurai plusieurs réponses qui vous
permettez vous entendez pas parler de
réhabilitation thermique des logements
nous on en parle pour le coup énormément
alors il y a des passoires thermiques il
y a les bouilloires thermiques parce que
quand on approche la des températures de
cet été et ça va être sale problème il y
a le problème des fils actifs dans les
professions qui sont suffisantes et moi
dans le Pas-de-Calais pour avoir essayé
de répéter mon logement c'était 18 mois
juste pour avoir le diagnostic parce que
selon où vous habitez en France il y a
pas les mêmes disponibilités des
artisans et des diagnostiqueurs etc donc
la réhabilitation oui les logements
vides oui les friches oui et ça permet
de préserver des terres agricoles et on
voit bien qu'on pourra pas continuer
tous à construire de nouveaux pavillons
flambants neufs dans des terres
agricoles si on veut préserver le climat
la planète les sols les risques
inondations et faire de l'alimentation
bio et locales ça veut dire d'avoir
localement autour de des écoles des
services publics et de là où ils
habitent les gens des champs après dire
qu'il y a pas de crise du logement enfin
c'est comme si vous vous disiez il y a
pas de problème de désert médicaux vu
que les médecins existent ils sont juste
pas au bon endroit c'est-à-dire que il y
a peut-être un problème d'allocation de
la population par rapport au logement
mais il y a quand même un problème et
puis il y a un problème d'accès
financier au logement notamment quand on
regarde depuis les années 60 ce qui
s'est passé les la part du logement dans
les dans les revenus dans les dépenses
d'un ménage chez les 10% les plus riches
c'était 10% et c'est réceptable à 10% de
leurs revenus donc ce que leur coûte le
logement dans leurs revenus depuis les
années 60 chez les 10% les plus pauvres
on est passé dans depuis les années 60
de 20% à 50%. et donc évidemment qu'il y
a un problème de logement de mal
logement de coût du logement de gens qui
profitent aussi de la pauvreté des gens
et qui des fois c'est limite de la
traite humaine et je vous donne un autre
chiffre quand vous habitez dans une
grande agglomération vous avez 60% de
chances que votre en fait les
multipropriétaires détiennent 60% du
parc locatif
60% du parc locatif c'est à dire que si
vous habitez vous avez vous êtes
locataire vous avez 60% de chances que
votre propriétaire est au moins 5
appartements qui le souhaitent en train
de louer donc il y a évidemment un
problème de logement
parce que on ne faites pas le coup de la
salade bio de traumatisé
terre
résidentiel évidemment mais vous pouvez
pas forcer les gens à aller vivre
ailleurs que là ils ont envie de vivre
ça pose un petit problème démocratique
quand même
ce qui est respectable avec lequel je
peux avoir des désaccords parfois vous
ne parlez pas du tout d'aménagement du
territoire vous ne parlez pas très peu
très peu en tous les cas on parle
beaucoup des villes on parle beaucoup
des centres urbains on parle beaucoup du
mal vive dans la grande ville mais on ne
parle pas des territoires ruraux
à la France vous savez on a lancé des
états généraux de la ruralité écologiste
de la ruralité écologiste avec une
grande université les 7 et 8 octobre à
10 dans la Drôme et on voit bien que la
ruralité c'est 80% du territoire en
France et c'est 30% de la population on
en parle jamais sur les plateaux télé
tout court c'est pas c'est pas 30%
et donc nos mères nous on a plus de 100
m en France évidemment qu'on parle en
priorité du maire de Strasbourg de Lyon
de Marseille que les gens connaissent
connaissent leur ville etc quand hier
j'ai débattu de de l'actualité j'étais
avec des maires de petites villes que
vous connaissez peut-être même pas et
eux ils voient bien quoi voilà qu'on
parle des grandes villes et jamais deux
et donc ce sur quoi ils alertent c'est
pas juste les gens viennent pas habiter
chez nous et j'ai besoin de sauver mon
école c'est comment voulez-vous qu'il
vienne vivre chez nous si on parle
jamais de nous nulle part si il y a pas
les services publics qui vont avec et
aujourd'hui ben les jeunes couples il
sait pas qui veulent pas aller
s'installer dans ces territoires c'est
qui calcule bah si pourront acheter du
pain s'ils auront accès à l'école pour
les enfants avec une jeune maman
évidemment mais vous voyez une jeune
maman qui qui veut des enfants le
rapport de la distance à la maternité
c'est hyper anxiogène pour quelqu'un qui
vit sa première grossesse et moi j'ai
connu des gens qui allaient s'installer
dans les coins pour à leurs enfants la
maternité fermée ils étaient enfin il y
a un truc anxiogène et donc moi je je
suis pour promouvoir ses territoires qui
sont extrêmement riches et voir là
encore à luc-sur-Aude dans du coup dans
l'Aude un maire écolo dans un village
258 de 250 habitants qui fait des choses
formidables parce qu'en plus il a du
foncier pour le coup pour faire sa
centrale solaire citoyenne pour faire
des documentaire générationnel et donc
il y a des choses formidables qui s'y
passent et l'Association des Maires
heureux de France serait d'accord avec
nous deux pour dire qu'on parle pas
assez de ce que c'est que vit dans ces
territoires pour le meilleur et pour le
pire sans doute mais c'est des sujets
qu'il faut qu'on adresse plus oui
politiquement peut-être qu'il faut tout
ramener dans la réalité pour qu'on en
passe dans les quand on en parle sur les
plateaux et c'est un peu oui mais en
revanche vous avez cité des maires de
grande ville moi il se trouve que j'ai
un passé professionnel en tant que
directeur d'organismes et
il y a quelque chose qui est un peu
secoué le monde HLM avec l'arrivée de
ces nouvelles équipes municipales c'est
que la protection de la biodiversité ce
qui est un objectif un enjeu et que je
partage a fait que certaines opérations
d'aide aménagement ont été extrêmement
ralenties et qu'on va même demander à
des promoteurs de retirer des permis de
construire déposés avec n'ont pas
l'Amicale menace en disant
ce serait mieux que vous ne construisiez
pas là et et on verra plus tard je
voudrais vous entendre parce que ça
secoue également des gens qui vous
défendent qui travaillent dans les
organismes HLM et qui avait cet objectif
de construire des réponses à la demande
quantitative dans les territoires et
pourtant et pourtant
la qualité c'est important aussi
la qualité mais ce que l'on construit
aujourd'hui n'est pas ce qui ressemble
aux années 60 et donc en fait il y a des
opérations qui se sont singulièrement
ralentis et dans l'attente de la
construction d'autre chose et il faut
que les équipes nouvelles arrivantes
arrivent à se mettre d'accord entre
elles mais pourtant ça ralentit ça
ralentit à Marseille dans des opérations
d'aménagement ça ralentit à Bordeaux ça
rend ça ralentit à Lyon comment est-ce
que vous expliquez ça ralenti à
Marseille je sais pas si vous êtes allé
récemment mais ça construit à tout va
notamment dans cette zone là autour du
port pas dans les quartiers nord mais
dans ce qui va se vendre très très cher
à 25 km de sa limite de son cœur de
ville et pour autant une étude menée par
Julien Normandie cibler 60000 logements
dans ma méta que ceux de la rue
d'Aubagne en cœur de ville évidemment
les chiffres qui hallucinaient sorti
notre programme c'est les
recommandations de l'OMS 5 minutes c'est
ce qu'il faut pour la santé pour le
social pour la santé on a compris que
vous alliez vérifier ce quasi monsieur
Jolivet ce que vous dites et si vous
voulez en en discutera il y a pas de
problème avec les maires à mes côtés
parce que je supprime toutes les
politiques municipales votre deuxième
sujet c'est l'état de la police oui je
j'ai le sentiment que les ce qui arrive
aujourd'hui une méthode pas beaucoup
alors ce qui met ce qui me surprend en
revanche c'est qu'on arrive à théoriser
politiquement les manifestations bon ça
c'est un et les événements dans la rue
c'est quelque chose d'assez nouveau ah
je trouve qu'on bon mais en revanche je
trouve que on cible beaucoup la police
alors sans doute sont-ils pas tous
parfaits mais on ne peut pas les jeter
dans les mêmes on peut pas prendre de
pain on ne peut pas les jeter tous dans
le même sac si je suis là
mais j'ai l'impression que j'ai
l'impression qu'en fait les forces de
sécurité intérieure sont beaucoup la
voiture balai de grandes insuffisances
de beaucoup d'administrations publiques
et on n'a pas su tirer les conséquences
de ce qui nous arrive
on n'a pas tiré les conséquences de la
monoparentalité on n'a pas tiré des
conséquences du travail dénu des femmes
au nom de l'égalité ce que je respecte
ce que je défends
parce que je défends mais
je je
m'aperçois aussi que
on a fait la dame où l'homme qui
travaille et qui est en horaire décalé
il a beau dire à ses enfants rentrer de
l'école à telle heure et notre henné il
n'est pas là pour vérifier les
administrations les services publics les
services publics qui soient scolaires
collèges ou lycée ce sont tous alors à
part les maires qui font un peu de
périscolaire après malheureusement c'est
aujourd'hui moi je suis favorable au
rétablissement des internats possibles
afin de donner la possibilité comme en
Allemagne de dire un enfant ben écoute
mon petit chéri demain moi je suis la
semaine prochaine je travaille de nuit
tu iras dormir à
l'internative
fermés pas du tout
c'est-à-dire de trouver des solutions de
relais des parents
écologistes qui sont députés et qui
n'ont pas solution pour leurs enfants
qui payent des frais de garde incroyable
en disant mais comment font les mamans
exactement
ne propose pas d'aide financière sur le
sujet des femmes qui sont députés avec
de jeunes enfants et parfois
monoparental donc c'est à toutes les
échelons
d'indemnités par mois mais je pense que
ce que vous dites juste c'est le c'est
la baisse des ils en revers chez les
vers une grande partie
relance
s'occuper de leurs enfants il y a un
vrai sujet de de recul des services
publics et ça vous avez raison et le
service public de la petite enfance tout
le monde l'a connu travaille mieux ou
pas avoir une solution de garde pour ses
enfants c'est toujours un truc hyper
stressant et c'est pas de la faute que
du travail des nuits des femmes mais
aussi du travail des hommes
publics de ces quartiers et le fait que
l'école évidemment qui a des écoles dans
ces quartiers quand elles n'ont pas
brûlé ces derniers temps mais qu'elle ne
permettent pas un ascenseur social
qu'elle permet pas de s'en sortir à
égalité réelle des chances pour un
enfant de ce quartier par rapport à un
dans notre quartier qui est dans une
autre école alors la solution
François Jolivet qu'en pensez-vous
l'internat alors ça fait un peu
répressif et puis j'ai l'impression que
à moi sur ma famille tous les gens qui
ont été à l'internat n'ont pas forcément
des bons souvenirs
11 km de chez lui aujourd'hui on lui
dirait non tu peux pas y aller parce que
tu es trop près de ton collège il serait
pas devenu ce qu'il est devenu
observer cette situation mais ça veut
dire que en fait vous enlevez
enfin je pense que pour des parents
c'est pas ce qu'il souhaite non plus il
va pas mettre leur ils veulent pas
mettre leurs enfants en internat et les
récupérer
par tout le monde moi je pense qu'il
faut permettre aux parents de trouver
des solutions et qu'aujourd'hui il y a
plein de solutions qu'il voudrait et qui
sont pas accessibles regardez avoir une
place en crèche à horaires décalé dans
ces quartiers et dans le reste de la
France c'est extrêmement difficile
pour les parents à qui on va finir par
expliquer là bientôt je le vois arriver
gros comme une maison que on va les
rechercher leur responsabilité pénale
pour des infractions que leurs enfants
qui effectivement sont inquiète est-ce
que ce serait quand même une solution à
laquelle que vous pourriez étudier ça
peut moi j'y avait travaillé pour la
Guyane figurez-vous c'était très
compliqué aussi les enfants étaient dans
la rue parce que là ils étaient ils
étaient l'internat mais l'internat fermé
le week-end et quand vous habitez à
Maripasoula et que vous avez deux jours
de pirogue pour y aller
parce qu'il fallait payer les
fonctionnaires le week-end il y a
beaucoup de suicides de jeunes et très
jeunes qui se
suicidents et donc ce qui est bien
d'accord sur quelque chose et ça sais
pas c'est sur le fait qu'il faut des
vrais services publics et qu'il faut
mettre en fait on a quand même des
services publics
des parents et leurs enfants merci de la
qualité de ce débats une dernière
question de Vincent roux qu'on retrouve
au figarologe oui avec un petit décalage
allez-y Vincent
alors un petit décalage une réponse
simple un marine Tondelier aujourd'hui
Marc la mort du dernier survivant du
français du débarquement c'était Léon
Gauthier membre du dernier vivant du
commando Kieffer quel serait l'éloge
funèbre de marine Tondelier
moi j'ai un infini respect pour ces
personnes qui ont défendu la France et
pour le pour qui à l'époque le courage
politique voulait dire bien autre chose
que que ce qu'on peut en penser
aujourd'hui donc c'est des gens qui ont
risqué leur vie qui ont donné leur vie
grâce à qui aujourd'hui normalement nous
sommes libres et donc c'est une page de
l'histoire qui se tourne et je trouve
que il y avait un moment où il y avait
une transmission directe de la parole de
ces personnes dans les écoles il pouvait
aller discuter transmettre leur mémoire
et c'est pas pareil que le lire dans un
livre d'histoire donc oui c'est un
moment infiniment émouvant pour moi et
je pense pour beaucoup beaucoup de monde
voilà pour l'écrire dans le Figaro
Vincent rot comme proposition absolument
merci beaucoup Vincent on retrouve la
semaine prochaine bien sûr vous êtes une
chef de partie heureuse
là en ce moment je sais pas qui arrive à
être heureux dans la séquence mais ça
n'est pas il est pas question de dire
que vous éclatez en ce moment même mais
vous avez pris la responsabilité d'un
parti c'est la première fois peu de
français vous connaissez qu'est-ce qui
vous fera le plus d'ailleurs dans cette
responsabilité depuis que vous l'avez
prise avant le corps la grande
solidarité de la famille écologiste
parce que je dois vous dire qu'on a vécu
des choses ces dernières semaines que je
ne souhaite à aucun chef de partie de
vivre par exemple on vous appelle pour
ce que vous avez un militant qui est
arrêté à 6h du matin par les services de
l'entité terrorisme pour une action à
laquelle il n'a pas participé d'ailleurs
et l'enquête l'a montré quand vous êtes
accusé d'être terroriste par le ministre
de l'intérieur c'est des choses qui sont
extrêmement lourdes et qui font qu'une
cible
cet esprit de famille vous vous pensiez
qu'elle était plus fracturée que ça ben
je peux vous dire que c'est des moments
où vous
c'est extrêmement violent en fait parce
que ça ça s'est retrouvé ça c'est
concrétisé comme une cible dans le dos
mise des écologistes sur le terrain il y
a eu une recrudescence des agressions y
compris envers les écologistes partout
en France pas que politique d'ailleurs
qu'il soit associatif journaliste et
donc c'est des moments qui dans lesquels
vous voyez vos forces et vos faiblesses
et en l'occurrence on a plutôt vu nos
forces de solidarité de cohésion et je
peux vous dire que quand on coupe touche
à un écologiste dans ce pays c'est à
l'ensemble de l'écologie qu'on touche et
on a plutôt montré notre sérénité notre
détermination dans ses épreuves et je
peux vous dire les écolos on fait corps
dans cet adversité que vous déplorez
merci beaucoup marine tandelier d'avoir
été l'invité d'audition publique ce soir
bonne soirée à tous on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]